[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
titled the next generation of ion
mobility
ms with structures for lossless ion
manipulation
i'm susie valdez elaborates and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
sponsored by
agilent so let's get started before we
begin i want to remind everyone that
this event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions
as you'd like during the presentation to
do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box
and click send please address the
questions to the specific speaker
that will help we will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble of seeing or
hearing this presentation
simply click on the ask a question box
located on that far
left of your screen i now present
today's speakers
dr kristen klein product manager lcq
top and i am qtof at agilent
technologies
and joining him is dr daniel debord
director
of r and d at mobile lion systems
for a complete biography of dr christian
klein and dr daniel
devord please visit the biography tab at
the top of your screen
welcome gentlemen dr klein you may now
begin your presentation
hello i would like to welcome you to
agilent's virtual mass spectacular
webinar series and
my name is chris klein i am the
executive and i am q tough product
manager
and i'm happy to go today with you
through the next generation of eye
mobility mass spectrometry
with structures for lossless iron money
collections
but before we kick off this series i
really want to go just a brief
introduction before i hand it over to
daniel dibord
and give you a bit of an overview what's
actually happened in high mobility
over the years so looking at the first
level
we already know from a long time from
paul angelo in 1905 about the eye
mobility theory
of course it took then a bit of time
with aston thompson in 1919
over 1965 mcdaniel and mason from the
transport iron
cases till finally 2003 was david
clammer
trapping irons and the first off
measurements this led later then in 2006
to the introduction of water's synapse
g2 in 2009 and the gs in 2011
both based on traveling rate system in
2014
agilent introduced the drift-based
immobility of qtov
which then followed later in 2016 rukers
tim stuff and then in 2019 again waters
circulation
this followed now in 2020 with mobile
iron and the structures
lossless iron money the weather's
actually eye mobility fit into and we
see that in the publication literature
a large number of thing applications
happening here
so basically from a lot of theoretical
aspects up to the year 2000
and then an explosion nearly of
exponential growth of all the different
application where eye mobility can be
used
and applied the reason for that is if we
really look where our mobility fits in
the spectrum
we really add a full spectrum into the
lcms by acquiring effectively high
mobility mass spectrometry frames
this four dimensional network
effectively consists of a chromatogram
the signal response
the eye mobility and drift time and of
course a mass spectra and oversee
so if you look at the different timing
on here the chromatogram
multiple seconds are fraction of minutes
whereas mass spectra typically on top
transients in the microsecond domain
we see that eye mobility in the
milliseconds to the second
fits exactly into this range and by that
can basically completely enrich with
another dimension
the separation within our technologies
applied
the 6560i mobility uh was a low field
drift tube
and it was based on the principle for
delivering highest collision
cross-sectional
accuracy it has a very defined length of
a drift cell
and it yields about a resolving power of
50. this is
combined with nearly 40 000 resolving
power of the q-top
gives us additional elements in
separation
but what does actually eye mobility
measure basically it moves from velocity
to mobility
to a collision cross-section we see at
the bottom the mason jump equation
where in black basically the only
variable parameters are shined which is
a drift time which is magnetic field
and the length of the drift cell once
knowing those parameters based on first
principle
the collision cross section can be
calculated
with that we are able now to look at the
confirmation of space occupancy from
biomechanics a
figure from the mclean lab already now
because
11 years old really saying that if we
look at
on the different molecular classes from
lipids peptides carbohydrate nucleotides
each of them have their own space within
the collision cross section
it can easily of course be separated
then it comes to the pact of
if i now look into the different classes
here i benefit substantially from a
further increased
resolving power of the eye mobility
space
and this is now actually my turnover to
daniel
who will show you exactly how the
structures of lossless iron
manipulations
boundary conditions of eye mobility
resolution are increased
substantially thank you for your
attention and daniel the floor is to you
hi my name's daniel the board and i'm
director of r d at mobile line systems
and i really appreciate this opportunity
to speak to you
about the work we've been doing at
mobile iron to develop the next
generation of iron validity mass spec
systems and they are based on
a technology known as structures for
lossless eye manipulations
so here's an outline of the topics i'll
be covering today i'll start with an
introduction to slim and how
we are able to use this technology to
achieve ultra high resolution eye
mobility separations
i'll then go into a few applications of
slim including a couple of
bio-therapeutic characterization
workflows biomarker detection
and finally demonstration of how slim
can achieve separation
of some challenging lipid isomers i'll
then finish up the presentation
with some recent work we've been doing
to implement high bit order multiplex
data acquisition in slim
so slim stands for structures for
lossless ion manipulations and describes
an approach to trapping and manipulating
ions
where we can use printed circuit board
technology to create electrode arrays
capable of transmitting ions
over very long distances slam was
originally developed at pnnl
and dr richard smith's laboratory in
2014
and has since then gained significant
recognition within the iron mobility
community
due to its position as the highest
resolution iron mobility technique
this technique has emerged at a time
when the i mobility mass spectrometry
field is exploding
as shown in the graph the number of
publications related to imms
has grown steadily over the past five
years to over 500 articles in just 2019
alone
despite its relatively recent
development slim has also
been well documented in the scientific
literature
the basis for the slim technology is a
precise arrangement of various electro
types on the surface of a printed
circuit board as shown on the diagram on
the top
left of the slide there are three main
types of electrodes included
the blue rectangles represent the guard
electrodes to which a dc
only voltage is applied the trapping
field generated by this voltage can be
seen on the figure on the right
where the dc guard electrodes serve to
confine the ions laterally
the red strips represent the rf
electrodes to which a high voltage
rf signal is applied to create a
trapping field which
which keeps ions suspended between the
two circuit boards
combination of rf and dc voltages
creates the trapping region shown in
green
and effectively forms an ion conduit
through which
ions can be passed very efficiently the
rainbow colored boxes in the top image
represent the traveling wave electrodes
which allow for controlling the motion
of the ions in the z-axis
as will be shown in the next slide
the figure on the bottom of the slide
shows the section view through the slim
device
where a phase shifted sine wave signal
is applied to each of the electrodes
to create a moving electric field that
propels the ions through the gap between
the boards
from one end of the device to the other
it's easy to see
how this moving electric field could be
used
could be stalled to trap ions
indefinitely or reverse
to change the direction of motion of the
ions
the true value of the slim electrode
geometry is that it is amenable to
directing ions in non-linear paths
this slide shows how ions can be
directed around a corner and along a
serpentine path by simply orienting
one lane of the slim device at a right
angle to the next
the black lines in the animation
represent the traveling wave potential
that pushes ions through the device
on the right side of the slide you can
see a typical
full-size slim board which has an ion
path length
of approximately 13 meters and has 44 of
these 100
180 degree turns this board which is
about the size of a briefcase
is installed in a vacuum chamber that is
maintained at between 1 and 4 torr
there are two main operating modes for
the sloan device that depend on the
speed and amplitude of the traveling
wave signal applied
the first is what we like to call
surfing mode where the traveling wave
speed is relatively
low and ions of different sizes will
travel through the device at
approximately the same speed
as you can see in the animation there is
no separation achieved
based on mobility under these conditions
if the speed of the traveling wave is
increased as shown in this animation
we encounter a different regime whereby
ions can be separated based on their
size to charge ratio
assuming these ions have the same charge
state the smallest ion will undergo
fewer collisions with the background gas
and will therefore travel at a speed
closer to that of the traveling wave
the larger ions will undergo more
collisions and not be able to keep up
with the speed of the wave
these ions roll over the wave more times
and take a longer period of time
to reach the exit of the device it is
this difference in ion arrival time
which is monitored to achieve the ion
mobility measurement
as shown on the previous slide ions can
be separated and traveling away by
mobility because they travel at
different speeds
the plot on the right shows an iron
trajectory simulation
of what of how the speed of an ion
changes as the signal frequency applied
to each of the traveling wave electrodes
is varied
as the frequency is increased the
largest ions
mass to charge 1522 from agilent tune
mix in this case
begins to fall off and can't keep up
with the speed of the wave
this happens for each smaller size of
ion sequentially
with a smallest ion keeping up with the
wave speed to the highest frequency
this plot shows a fixed amplitude but if
the amplitude is increased then the
speed of an ion will generally increase
as well
and so on this plot we can also see
where we would have surfing conditions
and at what point ions would transition
into the separation region
if we instead plot the arrival time
of the ions which is what we actually
measure in the experiment
we can see that there's an optimal range
of traveling wave frequencies
where we maximize the degree of
separation between each of the different
ion arrival times
this is somewhat analogous to the van
deeptr curve
from chromatography where with low
traveling wave speeds
we are separation limited because ions
are mostly surfing
and at high traveling wave speeds we
become diffusion limited
as ions are not effectively transmitted
to the weak effect of the traveling wave
field
from this plot one can see how the
traveling wave parameters can be tuned
to optimize separation based on the ions
of interest
slide shows the type
types of isomeric separations that can
be achieved using slam-eye mobility
starting from the top we can show two
sugar molecules that have a difference
in their size
or collision cross section of
approximately two percent
these compounds are isomeric which means
they have exactly the same
molecular composition and therefore
are indistinguishable by mass
spectrometry alone
and with ion mobility you can see that
we get a good degree of separation and
arrival times between these two
components
a slightly more challenging separation
is the example shown in the middle
where we have reverse peptide structures
that have a difference
in ccs of approximately one percent
even in this case we are still able to
separate those compounds
and even differentiate between those and
deamidation species as shown in the
middle
at the bottom we show a very challenging
case
of two lipid isomers which are
phosphoethanolamine lipids that have a
difference in their ccs values of
approximately 0.3 percent
and in this case we're able to achieve
some degree of separation
using the slim technology
so as shown before we have a degree of
freedom in slim
uh which is the path length of the board
that's used
and what we're showing in the plot on
the right is
how the resolution resolving power of
the ion mobility separation changes with
the path length
as shown by the red line the data shown
at left
represents a 13 meter path length where
the slam ccs resolution
achieved is in the range of 250 to 300
as demonstrated by the black line this
intersects the
the resolving power line at
approximately 280
and then i've also plotted the ccs
difference between two molecules
required to achieve a resolution
to peak resolution value approximately
one
and at 13 meters this works out to about
0.3 percent
so as you can see if there are more
similar compounds that should be
separated
we have the option of increasing the
slim path length to
improve the degree of separation between
those compounds and this has been
demonstrated numerous times at
pacific northwest national laboratory uh
even up to path lengths
over two kilometers
the trade-off uh that also needs to be
accounted for
as the path length is increased is that
the
arrival time or analysis time for each
of the ion mobility cycles increases
this increase is linear the increase
in resolving power behaves as a square
root
this slide shows some benchmark data
comparing
mobility resolution for a set of
pentacyclic saccharide
isomers across the mobile
13 meter slim system against the agilent
6560 drift tube iron mobility system
and the water synap g2 traditional
traveling wave system
as you can see both the agilent and
water systems
are able to achieve some degree of
separation between the three different
isomers
however the additional mobility
resolving power of the slim device
not only achieves baseline separation of
the compounds but also reveals
additional fine structure and
conformations
that aren't visible using the lower
resolution techniques
and here's another comparison of
slam-eye mobility performance relative
to some of the newer
imms systems you can see that
still higher resolution is achieved with
slim
so much so that we added an additional
compound to the isomeric mixture
this isomaltotriose component d
and we're still able to achieve
separation between the components a and
c
comparing to the the broker temstaff
system
and the water cyclic eye mobility system
and post-processing
of the agilent drift tube data using
their high resolution
demultiplexing algorithm if
the the relative spacing of the peaks a
and c for the other systems
would be compromised by introducing the
additional d
component
as i mentioned previously the sun
separation is performed at a pressure
between 1 and 4 torr
and this slide shows the effective
pressure
on the ion mobility arrival times as the
pressure changes
so what you can see here is plotting the
arrival time distributions
for a couple of agilent tune mixed ions
mass 622
and mass 1222 and we're
plotting the arrival time distributions
from over a pressure range of 2.43 to
2.63
and you can see how the the peak shifts
according to pressure
by plotting this arrival time
versus the slim pressure that it was
collected at
you can achieve a linear relationship
that shows how the arrival time
behaves with changes in pressure
and going back to uh the
equations that dictate the ion mobility
separation the nissan
we can see that the pressure which is
represented here
by the n variable which is actually the
density of the gas
and how it relates through the mobility
parameter
to the arrival time
turns out to be proportional as it
should be
and so this is a verification of that
constant
in the linear relationship between the
pressure and the arrival time
even with traveling wave iron mobility
the beauty of the slim eye mobility
technique is that it allows us to
digitize separations
which makes the analysis method more
reproducible and transferable
than typical chemical separations
as shown in the previous slide the ims
separation is dependent
only on the temperature pressure and
electrical potentials applied
and by controlling these parameters
we're able to generate
extremely reproducible ion mobility
peaks both in terms of arrival time
and peak area this data demonstrates the
type of signal stability
observed over an eight-hour period where
we observe
less than a five percent rsd variation
in the peak area
and less than point one percent change
in the arrival time
and all of this data was generated using
40 picogram injections flow injections
uh analysis for serpene molecule
and this is the molecular ion
so up to now i've described how we
achieved the mobility separation
with slam but equally important is
understanding how the slim device
integrates with a mass spectrometer to
generate
immense data this animation shows how
ions move
through the device
you can see that the liquid sample
is drawn through a capillary and
introduced
or ionized using electrospray ionization
and these ions that are formed are drawn
through a capillary and ion funnel
into the slim vacuum chamber where they
are accumulated on the slim board itself
by controlling the potentials and
direction of the traveling wave
we can then introduce this pulse of ions
into the slim device
and achieve the separation that's shown
here
as the ions enter the time of flight
device you'll see
on the top panel that the arrival times
are registered
in real time using the mass spectrometer
so ultimately we're able to generate
a two-dimensional data plot where we're
correlating the mass spectrum with the
mobility spectrum or arrival time
and this two-dimensional heat map
significantly increases
the heat the peak capacity of the
analysis
so this instrument configuration and
data structure is the basis for all of
the experimental data in the following
slides
so with that i'll transition to some of
the data that we've
been able to generate on some relevant
applications in
the characterization of biotherapeutics
the production of biologics is a 66
billion dollar industry
in which eight of the top 15 selling
drugs are based on monoclonal antibodies
and another three are also
large protein therapeutics monoclonal
antibodies
are much more complex than traditional
small molecule therapeutics
because they are derived from cells
rather than directly synthesized in a
laboratory
because of this we have to account for
biology in addition to chemistry
since structure dictates function in
many cases traditional
lcms approaches do not fully
characterize the structural variants
encountered throughout the various
phases of development production
the diagram in the top left shows the
high level structure of a monoclonal
antibody
the fab region is responsible for
antigen binding and differs
across different maps
the sc region is responsible for
determining the half-life in the patient
and is conserved across
monoclonal antibodies all of the various
colored circles represent various
post-translational modifications to the
protein's amino acid sequence
which must be characterized and
controlled to ensure safety and
efficacy of the product a ptm is a
structural variant that must be
understood in the process
so here we show some examples of how
slim can be integrated into
existing intact and subunit workflows
for this work we followed an existing
agilent 6545
xt application node method on the left
you have an example of slam
replacing lc and an example of
integrating into
and enhancing an existing workflow
on the left you can see a comparison of
two different analytical workflows one
using the standard lcms
and the other using direct flow
injection into a slam qtof system
this plot shows that similar relative
glycoform quantitation results can be
achieved
using a two minute imms analysis
rather than the five minute lcms
analysis
subunit data on the right is corresponds
to
lc slim ms data where we show that again
similar life like a form quantitation
can be achieved
while incorporating ion ability
separation at the subunit level of
analysis
the real value of the data on the right
should become apparent on the next slide
so here we can show that when analyzing
the fc region
of the imms data we encountered
an additional ion mobility p that was
somewhat unexpected
upon further investigation the data
suggests that this peak corresponds to
residual
intra-chain disulfide bonding in the
molecule
that results in a different
conformational structure
this is supported by comparing data from
a sample that was reduced
at an increased time and temperature and
this results
in predominant formation of the more
extended
conformational species the capability to
detect these types of disulfide isoforms
opens up the possibility
to take on crosslinking and disulfide
scrambling studies using this approach
we can also use slim to analyze the
digested protein
and achieve a significant reduction in
analysis time relative to a standard
lcms analysis
here we are showing full sequence
coverage of 98.7 percent
of the protein in a five-minute lc slim
ms gradient in addition to the typical
sequence coverage
information we also achieve
an additional level of information
regarding the
the different ptms that are present
for a deamidation modification
which adds plus one to the
molecule's mass in converting the
asparagine to aspartic acid or
isoaspartic acid
we can observe this also in the ion
mobility spectrum
so as you can see the
top panel shows the native species
for this peptide in which there is no
post-translational modification if you
go to a plus one state
we are able to see both the isospartic
and the
aspartic acid peaks
which have a slightly shorter arrival
time
than the native species
this can also be observed on an
additional peptide
where we have the native species and
with two potential
ptm sites for deamidation
we have a variety of different options
in terms of
isospark and aspartic ptms that are
possible at those locations
and that's observable in the eye
mobility spectrum as well
so transitioning to another application
where slim is a has some value
glycobiology biomarker research
is an area that has received significant
attention especially over the past few
months
due to the recognition that glycan
expression is largely it largely
determines interaction of the sars covi2
virus
however it's long been recognized that
these glycan molecules drive a lot of
the biomolecular signaling
and can serve as biomarkers in many
cases
the challenge in glycan analysis is due
to the large degree of structural
complexity involved
which is adequately addressed with
current solutions
so this slide shows some work that we've
done in collaboration
with the complex carbohydrate research
center at the university of georgia
and our collaborators there lance wells
and michael t meyer
on the bottom left panel you can see an
lcms analysis
result for per methylated in glycans
which were released from rna
d and fedorin that was collected by the
ccrc team
using a 180 minute lc gradient
you can see that they're able to achieve
some degree of separation
of the various glycan molecules but at
the expense of this extended analysis
time
in the bottom middle panel you can see a
two minute flow injection analysis slim
ms
result from the same type of sample
where we're able to achieve isomeric
separation across the various
glycant compounds the trace shown
represents doubly sodiated species of
all the molecules
but alternate charge species can be
further interrogated
to achieve further improvements in terms
of isomeric separation for some of the
compounds
and then finally the panel on the right
shows the quantitative capabilities from
this analysis
where similar quantitation profile can
be generated
in the two-minute method that
closely compares to the much longer lcms
method
and this can be observed by comparing
the relative heights
of the different bar plots against the
relative abundance mass spectrum where
you see a similar profile
and so overall we're able to achieve
very similar results
and realize an approximately 90 x
increase in throughput of the analysis
similarly in the analysis of oak glycan
standards we're able to achieve a
similar throughput increase
here this is a 100 minute lcms analysis
shown on the top
and then on the bottom we show again a
two minute flow injection analysis by
slim ms
and again pointing to the
reproducibility of the results
we're showing here for the various
glycan compounds that are detected
we have very good reproducibility in
terms of the peak abundance
as well as the arrival times or drift
times of the compounds
the final data slide here demonstrates
our capability
for all types of isomeric species
commonly found in lipids
the first pair of lipids shown on the
left
represent cis-trans isomers and so we've
got two sets of lipids
one for uh pc lipids and the other for
pe lipids
where the only difference between those
pairs is whether the
double bond is in a cis or trans
configuration
and this is a very common
modification between lipids that often
dictates
the function
of the lipid and here you're able to see
that we are able to achieve
baseline separation of these various
compounds
in the middle we show separation of
sn positional isomers and here this is a
much more challenging
mobility separation the compounds are
much more similar
in terms of their collision cross
section but still we are able to achieve
some degree of separation thanks to the
high resolving power
of the slam system and finally on the
right
we're showing separation of double pond
positional
isomers this is the case where the
double bonds are
at a different point along the fatty
acid chain
and still in this case separation is
achieved
for both pc lipids as well as
triglycerides
and i'd like to acknowledge that these
samples and this collaboration was in
partnership with john mclean at
vanderbilt
so with that i'll transition away from
data
and more towards a technology project
that's ongoing at mobileiron
where we're looking to integrate high
bit order multiplexing data acquisition
into our workflows
so the challenge with high resolution
eye mobility separation
is that as i've shown previously there
is a
trade-off in terms of resolution and
analysis time
and with standard signal averaging mode
we're typically accumulating ions for
approximately 15 milliseconds
and then separating them over a period
of 1500 milliseconds
for the full arrival time range
this plot shows how
the duty cycle of the system is affected
using this acquisition scheme
where the red signifies time period over
which we're accepting ions into the
system
and the white is where we're diverting
ions and not accepting them
and they don't make it to the detector
if we instead
consider the case of 4-bit multiplexing
this is a technique where we introduce
multiple packets of ions into the device
simultaneously or in sequence in order
to improve the duty cycle
the throughput of the system and in this
case four-bit multiplexing
corresponds to eight packets of ions if
each of those
is 15 milliseconds then we're
significant we're increasing the duty
cycle
by a factor of eight here
and so again the typical data set that
we're working to generate is shown on
the right
for agilent tune mix and
the challenge is that if we're
introducing multiple packets of ions
throughout the mobility separation
we ultimately end up with a convoluted
ion mobility spectrum
that must then be post-processed to
recover the original
mobility separation
so in hadamard transform multiplexing
we use a pseudorandom sequence of
injection pulses
that serves as a sort of key that allows
us on the back end
to decode the eye mobility data ion
mobility mass spec data that's generated
and that pseudorandom pulse sequence is
shown here in the top right
for the four bit case where we have
eight injection pulses
and they follow this sequence of ones
and zeros
on the bottom we're showing a two
dimensional heat map plot
of the multiplex data generated from a
six bit sequence
and you can see the degree of complexity
that's incorporated here
on the mass spectrum you can directly
interpret
this as a standard tune mix spectrum
but in the top mobility spectrum you can
see the degree of
convolution that's created through this
multiplexing process
if we zoom in on a single mass and just
look at this row of data and plot it in
a different manner
you can see the correlation between
single pulse data and various degrees of
multiplexing
so here we're showing extracted ion
mobiligrams for the m over z 922 ion
from agilent tune mix
so for single pulse data you get a
single ion mobility peak
for four bit data this is where we have
eight
packets of ions that are introduced and
just looking at the mass 922 ion you can
observe where those eight
ion mobility peaks arrive this can be
further increased
to 5-bit multiplexing
as well as 6-bit multiplexing
so at this point we have 32 pulses of
ions that are introduced to the system
but given that the eye mobility
resolving power of slim
is much higher than many of the other
commercial techniques we can go further
to
increase the bit order to 7-bit
8-bit and even 9-bit multiplexing
in the case of 9-bit multiplexing we
introduced 256
ion pulses per ion mobility cycle
so it's really incredible that we're
able to achieve this degree of peak
capacity
within the the ion separation time
and so as i mentioned the
native multiplex data is not inherently
useful
uh we need to be able to demultiplex
that and recover the original ion
mobility spectrum
but if that's achievable then there's a
significant increase
that's possible in the signal-to-noise
realm
so here we're showing uh the mass spec
data on the left
left and mobility data on the right for
agilent tune mix
at 4-bit 5-bit and 6-bit operation
as well as uh in black represents the
the single pulse
signal averaging mode and i'll point out
that all of the data that i've
shown previously was collected in the
signal averaging mode but not in
multiplexing mode so there are
significant benefits to be had by
moving into a multiplex data acquisition
regime
and so here you can see that the
increase in the number of pulses
directly corresponds to an increase in
signal intensity and therefore signal
the noise
of the resulting spectra
so in summary i hope that i've
been able to communicate that slim
offers a way to achieve
high resolution eye mobility separations
in a reasonable form factor
and in some applications high resolution
ims
can supplement or replace lc
and improve the method robustness and
throughput
and as in many cases
the high resolution eye mobility data
can reveal that next
level of structural information and find
structure
across a variety of different compound
classes
and at the end we looked at how
multiplex data acquisition offers a path
to further improve the performance of
the system and
enhance the images of utilization
efficiency
so in the preparation of these slides
i'd like to acknowledge
a number of our our team members here at
mobile line including jim arndt
kelly mosher and lulun ding who
collected most of the data that you
should saw today
i've also like to acknowledge the mobile
line engineering team
as well as our collaboration with gordon
anderson
and i'll also point out that this work
was done in collaboration with agilent
r d and in particular brian miller
george stafford
john feldstedt and chris decline have
been instrumental
in getting to the point where we are
today so i'd like to thank them for
their support
so again thank you to the audience for
your
attention and your interest in
structures for lossless eye manipulation
and mobile line systems thank you
and we will now start the q a portion of
the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on the
ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
so let's get started we have quite a few
questions already coming in gentlemen
our first question um
is what is the biggest protein you've
been able to analyze
with the system
so i think i can take that one the um
nist monopoly antibody is a 150 kilo
protein and represents the the largest
dime that we've looked at
and we're observing that at uh
charge states of approximately 50
to 40 plus so it puts it in overseas
range of
three to four thousand
thank you for that and what is the
typical injection
volume used for the slim flow injection
analysis
so most of the studies that we showed
today
we're using a 10 microliter injection
volume
thank you our next question is have you
done any
native protein analysis work
so this is something we're interested in
we've done a little bit of
scouting work and in particular looking
at
the protein streptavidin it's uh
often a good test case for demonstrating
native
protein analysis and so i can report
that we've been able to successfully
um ionize and transmit
uh the streptavidin uh in the native
state
but we haven't gone too far beyond that
yet
thank you dr the board and gentlemen
what if someone already
has a qtos can they upgrade their system
so um the intention is
that the mobileiron slam system is
suitable for
both new sales with new agilent qtos
and also if somebody already has the
agilent 6545 6545xt
or the 6546 then those systems are
are compatible with product and we would
be able as mobileiron to
offer that as a field upgradable option
thank you so much and i want to thank
our audience for these great questions
coming in we have time for a couple more
questions
how does the ion mobility software for
mobile lions
integrate with the agilent suite of
software
yeah so we've put definitely a lot of
effort and thought into
the the software development and
currently the
there are really two sides to the
question one is on the
control of the system and acquisition of
the data
and then the other half of the question
is you know
the processing and so on the control and
acquisition side
it really comes down to what mode the
system is operating in
so even after the slim device is
installed on a qtov
it still retains the ability to operate
as a standard utah system
and in that way the control and
acquisition of the system
is largely performed through the agilent
massage software
and then if the customer would like to
collect data in iron mobility mode
then we would use the mobile ion
software
to control the system and to collect
that data
but once the data is collected we
support conversion to the standard.d
format and at that point you're able to
pull the data
into the full suite of agile tools that
support
eye mobility mass spec data
thank you for that we have time for one
more question which qtop models will be
supported
with this system
yep so currently we've targeted
designing
towards the 6545 the 6545
xt and the 6546
models
thank you so much dr klein dr debord
thank you for your presentation today
would you like to provide any final
comments for our audience members before
we close
well um you know i again like to thank
agilent for this opportunity
to share our work uh and also the
viewers for their their time and their
interest
at mobile mobileline we're very excited
about the future of slim
and we look forward you know we didn't
mention it in the presentation but we're
targeting a commercial
product release in 2021
the data that you've seen is coming off
of our prototype and beta systems
but we're working towards getting that
out into
um you know the broader community
and so hopefully we'll be able to join
together next year for asms in
philadelphia
in person this time and i look forward
to sharing
some more of the incredible work that
our team and our collaborators are doing
with slim
and we feel that both on the development
side and on
the application side we've really only
scratched the surface
of what's possible with this
revolutionary technology
and so i encourage anybody that's
interested in learning more
about slim or what it might be able to
do in your application
that you'd reach out to us and we would
love to talk to you about it
thank you so much and dr klein did you
want to add anything
i would like to thank the audience for
participating in
agilent's virtual mass spectacular
events so thank you a lot for your
participation
and uh i'm sure that you are equally
excited about
the data that daniel presented the
capabilities that
the slim device can offer on agilent's
skeutoff and
with that i'm really excited to see this
moving forward into the next phase
and again thank you for a participation
in the webinar
thank you and john thank you again both
of you for your time
for your important research and before
we go i want to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
through june
of 2021. until next time
take care and be safe bye